le sky par att french open c'est un
tournoi handisport de grande ampleur il
se déroule cette année pour sa deuxième
édition vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines du 5 au 8 mai plus
de 300 projets se vont s'affronter pour
des places qualificatives au championnat
du monde nous allons suivre la première
journée de l'événement c'est parti
[Musique]
à
pour présenter un peu le tournoi on avec
geoffrey nisand habituellement tu es
directeur sportif au scalping
aujourd'hui organisateurs ça fait quoi
de changer un peu de rôles à c'est
totalement différent normalement je suis
derrière les joueurs et je coachais
j'entraîne là je les vois pas les
joueurs je suis plutôt sur
l'organisation et et faire en sorte que
tous les pôles du tournoi se passe bien
et voilà cette organisation-là ces
quatre jours intenses comment ça a été
pensé comme ça a été fait ici
du coup on a eu le premier tournoi en
novembre dernier qui on a mis un an pour
préparer sauf que pour passer sur un
coefficient 40 donc les plus gros
tournois internationaux on nous a
demandé de le faire en six mois ont
forcément un peu plus compliqué un peu
plus de travail mais le plus dur c'est
le début c'est pas les quatre jours de
compétition une fois que la compétition
est lancée c'est bon le plus dur c'est
toute la préparation
pour gérer tout ce qui va être transport
hébergement la salle respecter toutes
les normes etc pour la première édition
ça s'est déroulé à voisins le bretonneux
là c'est une enceinte un peu plus grande
ça change quoi
déjà ça change qu'on peut avoir un peu
plus de public donc on était limité à
500 personnes sur sur
voisins-le-bretonneux là on peut monter
jusqu'à 5000 même si pour l'instant on
n'a ouvert que 1000 places puisque on ne
savait pas comment c'était et surtout ça
nous permet d'être serein lieu sites
olympiques ce qui était très important
pour nous puisque l'objectif est de
postuler son tournoi de qualification
olympique et paralympique l'année
prochaine et aussi c'est pour avoir la
place du nombre de tables demandé pour
le cahier des charges l'année dernière
on était sur un
une salle de douze tables on doit être
sur une salle de 16 à 20 tables donc il
nous fallait une salle plus grande par
rapport à toutes les tables ce que tu
disais il ya sur les quatre jours de
compétition
d'abord c'est les championnats
d'un seul et on passe par équipes c'est
ça comment ça se passe les quatre jours
oui alors c'est les simples les deux
premiers jours par contre les par équipe
n'existe plus l'année dernière on a aidé
par équipes mais il ya une nouvelle
formule pour les jeux qui a amené les
double double dames double messieurs et
double mixte donc on est le troisième
tournoi cette année elle est testée donc
c'est encore en rodage au niveau de la
fédération internationale mais l'idée
c'est qu'on soit prêt pour les jeux de
paris ont peut-être un petit mot pour
les les pongistes du scalping ben merci
à eux surtout parce que il a fallu
beaucoup de monde pour organiser
heureusement cette année on était aussi
en co organisation avec la fédération
handisport ce qui nous a permis de
mutualiser de faire des binômes
bénévoles du club et salariés de la ffhg
franchement c'est top ça a super bien
marché donc merci à vous merci à tous
merci beaucoup de gens prennent dix ans
ce tournoi vous l'aurez compris c'est un
rendez vous international et qui dit
rendez vous international dit équipe de
france écoutez les réactions de la
manager et de fabien lamiraux multiple
champion olympique il ya 2 2 tournois
cruciaux dans la saison lascaux la
semaine prochaine donc en slovénie et
l'open de france qui sont vraiment les
deux plus gros tournoi de l'année et il
ya beaucoup beaucoup de points les
chercher c'est un système de ranking
comme au tennis pour qu'ils aillent se
qualifier notre objectif c'est à chaque
tournant top 3 mondial des nations
jusqu'au jus de paris une belle enceinte
c'est une belle enceinte qu'on découvre
généralement destinée à un autre sport
que le nôtre mais on s'en accommode ça
fait une belle ça une belle aire de jeu
plutôt conviviale avec des princes et
une balance entre une belle enceinte ou
alors on va se la pro à apprivoiser
tranquillement et parmi les français
présents ici plusieurs viennent
forcément du club local le scalping nous
avons rencontré deux d'entre eux lucie
et youri pour nous parler de leur
premier jour de la compétition je suis
donc avec lucie du scalping l'uci est ce
que tu me parle un peu de l'ambiance ici
comment ça se passe premier jour ouais
bien sûr alors moi j'ai pas encore
commencé je parle deuxièmes de poule
donc je commence à 14h30 je suis arrivé
un peu plus tôt pour supporter les tous
les français et puis je vais manger à
cet heureux et je vais commencer à
mettre dans ma routine a pris l'année
dernière le tournoi c'était à voisins le
bretonneux la c1 au vélodrome nationale
naissance un peu plus grand ça fait quoi
de jouer ici
les espaces de jeux sont plus grande je
trouve et c'est un coup être 40 donc en
fait c'est un plus gros tournoi essais
qualificatifs pour les mondes justement
qu'est-ce que tu vises toi tes objectifs
pendant ces quatre jours
gagner le plus possible de points et
et voir après parce que j'enchaîne en
fait je fais deux tournois aller en dix
jours j'enchaîne
saint-quentin-en-yvelines neutre et
j'enchaîne lascaux en slovénie donc faut
aussi avoir des temps de pause pour
pouvoir accumuler toute la fatigue qui
ont abandonné du jour et pouvoir bien
jouer aussi donc voilà écoutons va
suivre un peu pour courage pour ce genre
de compétition
[Musique]
je suis donc avec un autre joueur du
scalping yorick bonjour comment ça se
passe ce début de tournoi ce que tu as
déjà joué toi je viens de faire mon
premier match et il est perdu
jacques rocher alors j'ai joué le 7
mondial donc par plutôt favoris de mec
les premiers de poule et je perds je
perds 3 1 donc je suis prend 1,7 quand
même je le fait douter mais j'ai pas su
je pas su être rigoureux dans la
tactique et le fait que ce soit le
premier match aussi j'ai pas pu jouer
mon meilleur jeu et en même temps ils
expérimentent et il est devant donc pas
de regrets j'ai fait je pas fait un
mauvais match je pas content de moi
parce que j'ai perdu mais au fond moi je
me dis il faut quand même rester un
content de moi maintenant je raconte en
revanche comment comment ça va se passer
là la suite de la compétition il tresse
des matchs aujourd'hui et quels sont tes
objectifs alors là on est sur les matchs
de poules donc moi dans mon objectif
étant donné que suit 58 mondiale à
l'heure actuelle l'objectif c'est
simplement de sortir de boules parce que
là il ya les 20 premiers mondiaux mais
bon bah je suis un peu chez loin de la
liste mr deux cas l'objectif c'est de
gagner des matches si c'est possible de
sortir de poule donc gagner au moins les
deux prochains matches pour sortir de
paulois qu'est ce que tu penses de
l'ambiance ici du tournoi un peu
rapidement c'est super franchement
l'organisation super l'orgueil super le
staff est super et honnêtement il ya du
monde et franchement étonnamment bas
c'est kiffant quoi de voir tous ces gens
toute cette exaltation autour et tous
ces noms c'est un petit stress une
petite adrénaline supplémentaire de voir
les collègues aussi joué et tout c'est
très agréable by claude merci au rhic
bon courage pour la suite de la
compétition merci à toi au total 33 pays
représentant les cinq continents ont
participé à la compétition pour plus
d'un millier de match
[Applaudissements]